hey David Birney has been saying that on
day one he will legalize marijuana is
this actually possible I sort of have
dealt with this before when a caller
asked about it it's not possible so what
it really comes down to is when a
presidential candidate says on day one I
will do this that the other thing do
they literally mean on their first day
or I guess the first day is the
inauguration do they do they mean their
first day in the office which would be
the second day or do they mean this is
generally going to be a priority of mine
because there the reality is that when
it comes to something like legalizing
marijuana the executive branch certainly
could move a drug from controlled
substances schedule one by directing the
DEA to do it even if they did that it
doesn't happen in one day it takes
longer but even if you do it after a few
days or realistically it's something
that would take weeks or months it
doesn't undo state-level bans on
cannabis and you can't cancel those with
an executive order this actually has a
lot to do with states rights versus the
federal government so Bernie could say
on day one I have directed my Attorney
General not to do any prosecution raids
any anything at all when it comes to
cannabis in any state regardless of
whether that state has or has not
legalized cannabis so remember but under
Barack Obama's administration Obama
directed the Justice Department not to
go into states where marijuana was legal
despite it continuing to be illegal
federally Bernie could say we're going
to apply that to every state even in
Idaho where cannabis is illegal I still
don't want federal agencies going in
there and enforcing a federal drug
policy or whatever that's not a change
to the law but it does change the
enforcement but if cannabis is illegal
in Idaho Idaho police can continue to
prosecute that
to police it regardless of what it is
that Bernie signs in the Oval Office so
but what Bernie could relatively quickly
do would be immediately direct his
Attorney General not to police cannabis
in any state could start the process of
rescheduling cannabis away from Schedule
one but that's that's basically it so
the real question comes down to it's
actually a semantic question when it can
that it says I will do X Y or Z on day
one what does that really mean
does it does it mean day one does it
mean day two does it mean the first
month does it mean the first year let me
know what you think and if you believe I
am misunderstanding the law around this
I of course would love to hear from you
as well